everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and as you guys can
probably tell from the title of the
video we're going to be having a
subscriber contest so if you haven't
already subscribed you probably want to
go ahead and do that but I've been
posting videos now for about three
months we've already already got close
to 500 subscribers which is awesome and
talking to many of y'all it seems like a
lot of people are learning a lot I've
gotten to play chess with quite a few
you and I'm actually getting better
myself so I think all in all is this
chest channel has been pretty good for a
lot of people so I just kind of wanted
to give my appreciation to everyone for
making it such a success hopefully we
can continue to grow but for this
contest basically we're going to be
starting out small this one I'm going to
be giving away a chess set with with a
carrying case as you see right here it's
good for tournament play or if you just
want a chess set that you can carry
around very nice chess set so this is
going to be the prize in the first one
I'm going to try to have probably a
contest every month or two and hopefully
as it goes on and on I can get some some
different prizes maybe some some good
chess books that I've read or different
boards if you guys like these but here's
how it's going to work everyone that's a
subscriber gets one entry basically I'm
going to be putting a lot of entries
into a big hat if you will if your
subscriber you get one entry and you can
get up to 11 entries and I'll show you
how the easiest way you can just go to
my website a lot of you have a bookmark
which is awesome but you can get there
straight from this channel right here
it's just the chess website calm a lot
of you have checked out before and just
scroll down here and just click on
puzzles or you can click puzzles up here
and we're going to be working on the
first ten puzzles and so what I want you
to do is give me the answer the solution
for the first ten puzzles and each one
you get correctly you will get an
additional entry into the pot so just
for being a subscriber you get one and
then if you get all 10 to the puzzles
correctly you'll be at 11 and puzzle the
contest is going to run til July first
that's two weeks I'm actually going to
be out of town the next two weeks that's
why I wanted to do this while I was out
of town to give you guys something to
work on so when I get back in two weeks
I'm going to take all the injuries and
then draw a winner and I will notify you
on the comment board here and i will
also notify you personally so if you
haven't already go ahead and subscribe
to the channel here and then if you want
to get some extra entry you can just go
to the chess website calm and click on
puzzles and go ahead and solve these
puzzles and they are pretty tough if you
haven't looked at them already and I
want everyone if you would to email the
solutions don't post them or don't send
them to my YouTube email just send them
to the chest website @ gmail.com and
i'll have that over on the right-hand
column in the comments but it's just the
chess website at gmail com hope everyone
enjoys this whole contest good luck to
everyone and I will see you guys when I
get back thanks a lot